President Trump is going heavy-metal
tonight he says he will impose tough new
tariffs on imported steel and aluminum
it's a move he says designed to protect
vital American industries but critics
say will backfire hurt US consumers and
possibly ignite a trade war chief White
House correspondent John Roberts starts
us off again tonight with another
presidential move very few people saw
coming at least not today John Brett it
was really the timing of all of this at
the announcement that took everyone by
surprise the White House hasn't even
figured out how this is going to work
but the president was eager to get the
word out thank you very much everyone it
wasn't even on his public schedule today
and the White House insisted an
announcement wasn't coming until next
week but today President Trump unveiled
punitive sanctions on foreign aluminum
and steel 25% for steel it'll be 10
percent for a while the ad-libbed
announcement blindsided White House
staff the press secretary later insisted
it shouldn't be a surprise to anyone
after all the president talked at length
during the campaign about the impact of
foreign metals being dumped into the
United States but the stock market
tanked on the news of one point down
more than 500 points
former US Trade Representative Senator
Rob Portman is concerned the president
announced tariffs before any of the
finer details were finalized it depends
you know what countries might be
exempted which products might be
exempted so we don't know the details
yet I understand that was gonna come out
next week and the president kind of
preempted it with his comments today
Portman agrees with the president the
tariffs are needed to protect certain
steel companies and products essential
to national security but Republican
Senator Pat Toomey of Pennsylvania said
we should simply use existing laws to
combat dumping in a statement saying
changing course from this approach by
invoking national security as a means of
imposing new huge tariffs on all kinds
of imported steel is a big mistake that
will increase costs on American
consumers cost our country jobs and
invite retaliation from other countries
the action is predominantly aimed at
China which has been dumping cheap steel
products into the US for
decades you like the tariffs that we are
talking about you like the tariffs where
they won't be dumping on our country
what they do is they dump massive
amounts of product in our country and it
just kills it destroys our companies and
our jobs but the move may also affect
America's closest allies Canada declared
any tariffs against its steel would be
unacceptable Britain said we are
particularly concerned by any measures
that would impact the UK steel and
aluminium industries one group that
definitely likes the plan the steel and
aluminum company chiefs who met with the
president today we're convinced that we
will see very quick action definitive
action and action that is meaningful
meaningful and long-lasting and a day
after the White House communications
director hope Hicks announced that she
would soon be leaving the White House
was shooting down reports that the
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
was on his way out the door in a
statement the White House saying there
are no personnel announcements at this
time Brett will follow it John thank you